This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's the end of the year and it's time for our annual mini-stories episodes. Maybe if I knew five years ago that these episodes would become an audience favorite and we do them every single year, I might have come up with a better name than mini-stories, but here we are. You got to dance with the girl that brought ya. Mini-stories are fun, quick hit stories that maybe came up in our research from their
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。年关将至，又到了我们一年一度的迷你故事特辑时间。也许五年前如果我知道这些特辑会成为听众的最爱，并且我们每年都会做，我可能会想出一个比“迷你故事”更好的名字，但事已至此。你得跟带你入场的人共舞。迷你故事是一些有趣、节奏明快的短小故事，它们可能是我们在研究
episode, or it was just some cool thing someone told us about and we found really interesting, but they didn't quite warrant a full episode in two months of hard reporting. But they are great 99 PI stories nonetheless. And my favorite part is we do them as unscripted interviews where I'm in the studio interviewing the people who work on this show who I like and off a lot. Sometimes I know a little bit about what they're going to talk about and sometimes I know nothing. It is very fun, especially for me. This week we have stories about mistaken identity, unreachable iconic tour destinations, haunted
某个单集时偶然发现的，或者只是别人告诉我们的某件酷事，我们觉得非常有趣，但它们又不足以支撑长达两个月的艰苦报道来做成一期完整的节目。不过，它们依然是很棒的“99 PI”故事。我最喜欢的部分是，我们以无剧本采访的形式来做这些故事，我在录音室里采访制作这个节目的同事们，我非常喜欢他们。有时我对他们要谈论的内容略知一二，有时则一无所知。这非常有趣，尤其是对我而言。本周我们带来的故事关于认错人、无法到达的标志性旅游目的地、闹鬼的
architecture, and of course, raccoons. Stay with us. So I'm in the studio with Emmett Fitzgerald, and I'm told you have a story about a park. Yes, a park in Ottawa, Canada, called Jack Purcell Park. And you know, it's a pretty ordinary looking park in many ways. It's a little pocket park with some grass, some trees, community center. But there's one kind of distinctive feature, I would say, to the park, which is the light fixtures.
建筑，当然还有浣熊。请继续收听。我现在和埃米特·菲茨杰拉德一起在录音室里，听说你有一个关于公园的故事？是的，是加拿大渥太华的一个公园，叫做杰克·珀塞尔公园。你知道，从很多方面来看，它都是一个非常普通的公园。它是一个带有一些草地、几棵树和一个社区中心的小型口袋公园。但我要说的是，这个公园有一个比较独特的特征，那就是灯具。
Okay. So take a look at this picture. So they're, they look like they're about 8 feet tall. There's a post and a oval on top of it kind of looks like like lollipops, like a tennis racket or something like that. Yeah. Okay. So hold that thought.
好的。那么看看这张照片。它们看起来大约有8英尺高。有一根柱子，顶部是一个椭圆形，有点像棒棒糖，或者是网球拍之类的东西。对的。好，那先记住这个画面。
Okay. Okay. So back in 2014, a reporter for the Ottawa citizen, a Matthew Pearson stumbled upon these strange looking lights. I was new as a city hall correspondent at the time and I asked the city counselor and she just said, you should do some digging and you should go visit the city archives and look up Jack Purcell. That's what Matthew did.
好。好的。早在2014年，《渥太华公民报》的一名记者马修·皮尔森偶然发现了这些看起来很奇怪的灯。当时我是市政厅的新闻记者，我问了一位市议员，她只是说，你应该去挖掘一下，去看看市档案馆，查查杰克·珀塞尔。马修就是这么做的。
He went to the city archives to try to figure out who was this guy that the park was named after because maybe that would give us some clue as to like why these lights look this way. And pretty quickly he learned that Jack Purcell was just kind of a regular local guy who was known around the neighborhood for fixing hockey sticks back in the 50s and 60s. Cool. The Jack Purcell for whom the park is named is a man who lived in Ottawa. He was a postal worker and he was nicknamed the Stick Doctor because he was really good at and liked repairing broken hockey sticks in his basement for kids who played probably street hockey in the neighborhood.
他去了市档案馆，想弄清楚这个以他的名字命名的公园到底是何方神圣，因为这或许能给我们一些线索，解释为什么这些灯会是这个样子。结果他很快了解到，杰克·珀塞尔其实只是当地一个普通人，在50年代和60年代，他因在附近帮人修理曲棍球棍而远近闻名。酷。公园以其命名的这位杰克·珀塞尔是个住在渥太华的人。他是一名邮政工人，绰号叫“球棍医生”，因为他非常擅长而且喜欢在地下室里为那些可能在社区里玩街头曲棍球的孩子们修理断掉的曲棍球棍。
When I went to the city archives to read about him, I found out that in one hockey season alone, he m meant 175 sticks. It's funny, maybe this is just the American Emmy, but naming a park and a community center after a local man known for generously repairing children's hockey sticks feels like so amazingly Canadian. Ha ha ha, that's kind of you. Ha ha ha, well it's so sweet.
我去市档案馆翻阅关于他的资料时，发现仅在一个曲棍球赛季里，他就修理了175根球棍。说来也搞笑，也许这只是美国人的视角，用一个以慷慨修理儿童曲棍球棍而闻名的当地人的名字来命名公园和社区中心，感觉太具有加拿大特色了。哈哈，你真会说话。哈哈，这太暖心了。
Well what a great person to honor, but I can't quite figure out how to connect the lollipops to, you know, like repairing hockey sticks. Yeah, yeah, it doesn't, it doesn't make sense, but try googling Jack Purcell. Okay. Okay. So, as Jack Purcell, Edward, John Edward Jack Purcell was a Canadian world champion, Batman player.
嗯，这是一个多么值得纪念的伟大人物啊，但我怎么也想不明白，棒棒糖怎么能和修理曲棍球棍联系起来。对啊，这说不通，不过你可以谷歌一下杰克·珀塞尔。好吧。好吧。那么，作为杰克·珀塞尔，爱德华·约翰·爱德华·杰克·珀塞尔是一名加拿大世界冠军、羽毛球运动员。
Purcell was the Canadian national badman champion in 1929, 1930. The third world champion in 1933 even has a shoe named matrim from Converse. So those are badminton rackets. They're badminton rackets. And this, this is a different Jack Purcell. A different Jack Purcell who also happens to be a Canadian athlete. Oh my goodness. But he is not the Jack Priscell that the park was named after. And so I love it. You have these
珀塞尔是1929年、1930年的加拿大全国羽毛球冠军。1933年的第三届世界冠军，甚至连匡威都有一款以他名字命名的鞋。所以那些是羽毛球拍。那是羽毛球拍。而这，这是另一个杰克·珀塞尔。另一个恰巧也是加拿大运动员的杰克·珀塞尔。噢，天哪。但他并不是那个公园以其命名的杰克·珀塞尔。所以我太喜欢了。你们这些
lighting fixtures that are very lovingly designed in honor of the wrong Jack Priscell. Of the wrong Jack Priscell. That's awesome. And Matthew reported that in total, they cost about $50,000. The city counselor who, you know, tipped Matthew Pearson off to this whole thing. She said to me, I think he just Googled Jack Purcell and the only thing that comes up is the badminton player. The Ottawa Hockey's chick helper outer of kids
灯具的设计非常用心，结果却是为了纪念错误的杰克·珀塞尔。纪念了错误的杰克·珀塞尔。这太棒了。马修报道说，这些灯总共花费了大约5万美元。那位给马修·皮尔森提供线索的市议员对我说，我想他当时只是谷歌了一下“杰克·珀塞尔”，而搜出来的全都是那个羽毛球运动员。那个帮孩子们修曲棍球棍的渥太华本地人
doesn't come up on Google. I mean, that's a real lesson in research. We come across that type of thing all the time too, basically. Wikipedia is this great resource, but sometimes they don't have entries for the kind postal carrier who repairs Hockey sticks. Right, right.
根本不会出现在谷歌搜索结果里。我的意思是，这真是给我们上了一课关于资料调研的课。我们其实也经常遇到类似的情况。维基百科是一个伟大的资源，但有时他们就是没有那些热心修理曲棍球棍的邮递员的词条。没错，没错。
And so the designer of these lights, they admitted that that was what they were following. Yeah, so Matthew talked with the designers and they admitted that that was what they were following. Yeah. So Matthew talked with the designers and they admitted that initially they had at least they had designed the lights in honor of Badminton, Jack Purcell. And in fact, the original design called for the racket shaped light fixtures to be strong like real rackets.
所以这些灯的设计者承认，这正是他们当时参考的对象。是的，所以马修和设计者们进行了交谈，他们承认这确实是他们参考的对象。是的。所以马修和设计者们进行了交谈，他们承认最初时，至少他们的设计是为了致敬羽毛球手杰克·珀塞尔。事实上，最初的设计要求将拍子形状的灯具做得像真正的球拍一样穿好球线。
But that part of the plan was next. You know, presumably when they figured out their mistake. Although they, you know, it gets a little sticky here, but the designers told Matthew that at that point, they had completely redesigned the light fixtures to look like stylized trees. Although I think to Matthew and kind of anyone looking at them, they still look pretty suspiciously like
但计划的那部分被取消了。你知道，大概是当他们发现自己搞错的时候。尽管他们，你知道，这里有点棘手，但设计者告诉马修，当时他们已经把灯具完全重新设计成了风格化的树木造型。不过我认为对马修以及任何看着它们的人来说，它们看起来仍然非常可疑地像是
unstrung badman records. And kind of anyone looking at them, they still look pretty suspiciously like un- Un-un-unstrung badman rackets. You know, I don't think, I basically what I'm saying, and it is I don't think people bought the suggestion that they were stylized trees. So, but I can see how they would get confused and maybe make these lights, and they are stylized enough, they're pretty, you know, so it makes sense to choose them. But like, how did someone from the city government not notice and how do you get through? Yeah, I mean, I had this question too,
没有穿线的羽毛球拍。而且任何看到它们的人都会觉得，它们依然非常可疑地像是——没穿线的、没穿线的、没穿线的羽毛球拍。你知道，我不认为……我基本上想说的是，我不认为人们会相信它们是风格化树木的说法。所以，我能理解他们为什么会搞混，也许会制作出这样的灯，而且它们的风格化程度也够了，挺好看的，你知道的，所以选择它们也合情合理。但话说回来，市政府怎么会没人注意到呢？这怎么能通过审核呢？对啊，我的意思是，我也有这个疑问，
and Matthew isn't exactly sure about that. But I think, you know, the truth, the more I think about it, the more I think it's totally possible that the people who commissioned the park redesign and looked at those plans also didn't know. Which Jaguar sound the park was the same as that? Because he's a world class Canadian athlete. Right, totally.
而马修对此也不是十分确定。但我想，你知道真相是，我越想越觉得完全有可能的是，那些委托进行公园改造设计并审阅图纸的人当时也不知道公园是以哪位杰克·珀塞尔命名的。因为他可是一位世界级的加拿大运动员。对，完全如此。
If you were gonna design a park after a recreation center, named after a person named Jack Bracell and there happens to be a very famous Canadian athlete named Jack Bracell, it hardly seems unreasonable that that would be what the park was named after. And in fact, back in 2014, Matthew reported that one of Badminton Jack Purcell's great granddaughters
如果你要设计一个以一个名叫杰克·珀塞尔的人命名的娱乐中心为依托的公园，而恰巧又有一位非常著名的加拿大运动员也叫杰克·珀塞尔，那么公园是以他命名，这似乎一点也不显得不合理。事实上，早在2014年，马修就报道说，羽毛球手杰克·珀塞尔的一位曾孙女
or several family members of Badminton Jack heard about the park and they took a visit. And people on staff there told them that the park was they took a visit and people on staff there told them that the park was named after a local man who repaired hockey sticks and was also a world champion pad. Right, right. So no one knows the story.
或者羽毛球杰克的几位家属听说了这个公园并前来参观。那里的工作人员告诉他们，这个公园——他们来参观时，那里的工作人员告诉他们，这个公园是以一位修理曲棍球棍的当地人命名的，他同时也是一位世界羽毛球冠军。对，对。所以没人知道真实的故事。
Everyone is confused in this story. Yeah, exactly. That's amazing. And you know, the more I talk to Matthew, like I think I when I first heard this story, I was like, oh, those idiot designers. But the more I thought about it, I mean, it's just like, I have was like, oh, those idiot designers. But the more I thought about it,
在这个故事里每个人都糊涂了。对，没错。太神奇了。而且你知道，我跟马修聊得越多，就觉得——我刚听到这个故事时心想：“哦，这群白痴设计师。”但当我深入思考后，我的意思是，这就像——我当时想：“哦，这群白痴设计师。”但当我深入思考后，
I mean, it's just like, I have total sympathy. They made a mistake. At the same time, at least, they were actually trying to figure out who Jack Purcell was and based the design off of this character. And it just seems pretty reasonable to me that a community center in Park in Canada would be named after a famous Canadian athlete,
我的意思是，这就像——我完全表示同情。他们犯了个错误。与此同时，至少他们是真的试图去弄清楚杰克·珀塞尔是谁，并根据这个人物来进行设计。在我看来，加拿大的一座社区中心和一个公园以一位著名的加拿大运动员命名，是非常合理的，
this famous Canadian Badminton champion. If the park had been named for the badminton player, you couldn't come up with a better lamppost, light fixture feature than these things. They do. They really look like badminton racquets. Yeah, they look like badminton racquets. They are not, they don't look like stylized trees. I think you're right to have sympathy for the designers because the client should tell you what the significance of the person is that they're honoring. And that was, I think that was their responsibility.
这位著名的加拿大羽毛球冠军。如果这个公园真的是以这位羽毛球运动员命名的，你绝对找不出比这些灯柱、灯具更好的特色设计了。它们确实很像。它们真的很像羽毛球拍。对，它们看起来就像羽毛球拍。它们一点也不像风格化的树木。我觉得你同情设计师是对的，因为客户应该告诉你他们所纪念的人有什么重要意义。而我认为那是客户的责任。
Yeah. Yeah. To me, it's just a story about the way legend builds and people, you know, like, you know, it's like, I love the idea that if Matthew hadn't broken this story for the Ottawa citizen that like 200 years in the future There's just a truth that is there's this amazing Canadian who is both a hockey stick-mender and a badman champion And he has bet any of this rec centers named after him or throughout the city like I you know
对。对。对我来说，这仅仅是一个关于传奇如何构建、人们如何……你知道，就像，我特别喜欢这种想法：如果马修没有为《渥太华公民报》独家爆料这个故事，那么在两百年后，就会存在这样一种“真相”：有这么一位了不起的加拿大人，他既是曲棍球棍修理匠，又是羽毛球冠军，城里到处都是以他名字命名的娱乐中心。就像，你知道的——
But things like that I'm sure happened. I do not doubt it. That's amazing. What a great modern day example of that type of thing of like I do not doubt it. That's amazing. What a great modern day example of that type of thing of like historic monument like setting people's Mines us to how someone or some thing should be remembered the stick doctor became the greatest badman player in the world Just because of a monument, right That's awesome. He's got a shoe named after him Well, thanks so much, Emmett. Thank you. That's producer Emmett Fitzgerald.
但类似这样的事情我确信是会发生的。对此我深信不疑。太神奇了。这真是一个关于这类事情的绝佳现代版例子，就像——对此我深信不疑。太神奇了。这真是一个关于这类事情的绝佳现代版例子，就像历史纪念碑如何左右人们对于某人或某事应该被如何铭记的看法。“球棍医生”竟然成了世界上最伟大的羽毛球手，仅仅因为一座纪念碑，对吧？这太棒了。他甚至还有一款以他名字命名的鞋。好吧，非常感谢你，埃米特。谢谢。这是制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。
Thanks to a listener named Nancy Norton, who wrote in with the story of Jack Purcell Park. Up next, Chris Baroube. So I'm now talking with Chris Berube, who is in Canada, actually, doesn't work in Oakland. Yes, I am. That's right. And actually, Roman, it is cold here.
感谢听众南希·诺顿（Nancy Norton）发来关于杰克·珀塞尔公园的故事。接下来是克里斯·巴鲁贝。我现在正在跟克里斯·巴鲁贝对话，他其实在加拿大，不在奥克兰工作。是的，我是。没错。而且说真的，罗曼，这里很冷。
I don't know if you knew this back Canada at this time of year. I suspect it as much. So Roman, I actually have a story for you that is about the Hollywood sign, which I think is just me taking like a vacation of the mind by doing a story about Los Angeles right now. Do you know the whole story of the Hollywood sign, which I think is just me taking like a vacation of the mind by doing a story about Los Angeles right now. Do you know the whole story of the Hollywood sign?
我不知道你是否知道加拿大现在的这个时候是什么样。我大致能猜到。所以罗曼，我其实有一个关于好莱坞标志的故事，我觉得这就像是通过做一期关于洛杉矶的节目来让我的心灵度个假。你知道好莱坞标志的完整故事吗？我觉得这就像是通过做一期关于洛杉矶的节目来让我的心灵度个假。你知道好莱坞标志的完整故事吗？
Like do you know how it started? Not exactly. I do remember that it used to be Hollywood land. That's the only thing I can really recall. That's right. It started in the 1920s. It was actually a real estate ad when they built the Hollywood sign. It was supposed to get people to move into the Hollywood land neighborhood.
比如你知道它是怎么开始的吗？不完全知道。我只记得它以前是“Hollywoodland”（好莱坞乐园）。这是我唯一能记起来的事情了。没错。它始于20世纪20年代。当他们建造好莱坞标志时，它其实是一个房地产广告。它的目的是吸引人们搬进好莱坞乐园社区。
And then over time, they left it up. It sort of became this icon. Actually, it really fell into disrepair in the 70s. So I sent you a photo if you want to take a look at it. Okay. Oh, wow. You mean really falling into disrepair? There's basically no H.O. Two of the O's are almost completely down. It's a disaster. I had no idea it got in that bad. Yeah, it looks like a tornado actually came through and demolished it basically. And it was just kind of rotting on the side of Mount Leigh for a long time. And then a bunch of celebrities came together and led by Hugh Hefner. There was a huge fundraising drive.
后来随着时间推移，他们把它保留了下来。它某种程度上成了这样一个标志。事实上，它在70年代确实严重失修了。所以我给你发了一张照片，如果你想看的话。好的。噢，哇。你是说真的严重失修吗？基本上连H和O都没有了，两个O几乎完全倒塌了。这真是一场灾难。我不知道它当时破败成这样。是的，看起来就像龙卷风过境把它给彻底摧毁了一样。而且它在李山的山坡上腐烂了很长一段时间。后来一群名人聚在一起，在休·海夫纳的带领下，开展了一场巨大的筹款活动。
Actually, Hefner saved the Hollywood side twice. It was Playboy Enterprise's founder, found her you have to do guaranteed success back in nineteen seventy eight have to read the effort to rebuild the tattered hollywood sign this time you provide to the final nine hundred thousand dollars to preserve the land to the west of it well say what you will if you have no there's a complicated feelings about that guy but he
其实，海夫纳拯救了好莱坞标志两次。他是花花公子企业的创始人，创始人休·海夫纳在1978年保证了成功，海夫纳领导了重建破败的好莱坞标志的工作，这一次你提供了最后90万美元来保护它西部的土地。好吧，不管你怎么说，如果你没有……对那家伙有复杂的感情，但他
he is responsible for the hollywood side as we know it the hollywood side will welcome Dreamers and artists and Austrian bodybuilders from around the world to continue coming over here for generations to come. So the Hollywood sign becomes this icon, tourists come from everywhere to see it, and you can kind of see the Hollywood sign in a lot of parts of LA, if you're just driving around your book and you'll be like, oh, there's the sign.
他是我们所知道的好莱坞标志的幕后功臣。好莱坞标志将迎来自世界各地的梦想家、艺术家和奥地利健美运动员，让他们在未来世世代代继续来到这里。于是，好莱坞标志成了这样一个偶像，游客们从四面八方赶来观赏它，你在洛杉矶的很多地方其实都能看到好莱坞标志，如果你只是开车兜风，你会突然觉得：哦，那个标志在那儿。
But lots of people come to LA and they really just want to get close to it. Like they want to get up close, they want to have like a selfie with it. But the problem with the Hollywood sign is a tourist destination is that it's actually like really hard to get to. So the Hollywood sign is on top of a mountain
但许多人来到洛杉矶，他们真的只是想靠近它。比如他们想近距离接触，想和它合个影。但好莱坞标志作为一个旅游目的地的最大问题在于，它其实——真的很难到达。所以好莱坞标志在山顶上，
and the mountain is in Griffith Park. So to get there, you actually have to park somewhere and then you have to do a whole elaborate hike up to the sign to get a really good close-up view of it. I see. I see. So you can't drive that close to it. So what are tourists doing? Where do they park to go there? Well for years, they actually didn't really do anything. Tourists would show up in LA. They'd ask people, where's the Hollywood sign? And then someone would be like, well, you have to park here and then you have to do
而这座山在格里芬公园里。所以要到达那里，你实际上必须把车停在某个地方，然后必须进行一次精心策划的爬山远足，才能近距离欣赏到它的美景。原来如此。原来如此。所以你不能开车离它太近。那游客们都在做什么？他们把车停在哪儿去那里呢？好吧，多年来，他们其实真的什么也没做。游客们来到洛杉矶。他们问别人，好莱坞标志在哪里？然后就会有人说，哦，你得把车停在这里，然后你必须完成
this whole hike. And then often people would just give up. People wouldn't come up here. They wouldn't know how to get around our neighborhood. So this is Sarah Jane Schwartz. She's an actress. She's lived in the Beachwood Canyon neighborhood for over 40 years.
整个这段远足。接着人们往往就会放弃。人们不会上来。他们不知道怎么穿过我们的社区。这就是莎拉·简·施瓦茨（Sarah Jane Schwartz）。她是一名演员。她在比奇伍德峡谷（Beachwood Canyon）社区住了40多年。
So her home is like right under the Hollywood sign. You maybe have somebody ask you once a month, how do you get to the sign? And you talk to them for 20 minutes, you'd ask where they were and they tell you about their life and you were friendly and very hospital to Taurus because they were a rarity. But Sarah Jane says around 2005,
所以她的家就在好莱坞标志下方。你可能每个月都会遇到有人问你一次：“怎么去那个标志那儿？”然后你会跟他们聊上20分钟，问他们来自哪里，他们会向你讲述他们的生活，你对游客非常友好和热情，因为他们很罕见。但莎拉·简说，大约在2005年，
two big things happened that changed everything. So the first was GPS came around. So suddenly everybody had a map in their pocket. So the first was GPS came around. So suddenly everybody had a map in their pocket. So if you wanted to figure out a way to get up to the Hollywood sign, you could just consult the map on your phone and you always had a way to figure out where you were. And then the second thing was the rise of articles and YouTube videos. Hey guys, I'm Amber and welcome to the top of the Hollywood sign. How cool is this? This is one of my favorite hikes in all of LA. So today I'm gonna show you just how to get here.
发生了两件大事，改变了一切。第一件是GPS的出现。所以突然之间，每个人的口袋里都有了一张地图。所以第一件是GPS的出现。所以突然之间，每个人的口袋里都有了一张地图。所以如果你想找出一条去好莱坞标志的路，你只需查阅手机上的地图，你总能找到弄清楚自己位置的方法。第二件事则是文章和YouTube视频的兴起。嘿，大家好，我是安珀，欢迎来到好莱坞标志的顶端。这有多酷？这是我在整个洛杉矶最喜欢的徒步路线之一。所以今天我将向大家展示如何来到这里。
Let's go. Amber seems excited. Yes, you're going up to the Hollywood sign. Man, you're having a great day. That's a perfect day. All right guys, so it's super early because we decided to do a sunrise hike. But getting started, this is where you park.
我们走吧。安珀看起来很兴奋。是的，你要去好莱坞标志那儿。老兄，你今天过得太棒了。这是完美的一天。好了，各位，现在时间还非常早，因为我们决定进行一次日出徒步。刚开始出发时，这就是你停车的地方。
Grid in a LA, so make sure you read the street signs, but you can just park anywhere along this residential neighborhood and you should be good. All right, ready? Let's get started. So it's 6am and they're instructing people to park in a residential neighborhood. Yeah, and guess what, that's Sarah Jane's neighborhood. The trailhead that is being recommended is like, right where Sarah Jane lives.
洛杉矶是个网格状城市，所以请务必看清路标，不过你基本上可以把车停在这个住宅区的任何地方，那就没问题了。好了，准备好了吗？我们开始吧。所以现在是早上6点，而他们正在指示人们把车停在一个住宅区里。是的，你猜怎么着，那是莎拉·简的社区。他们推荐的徒步起点，正好就在莎拉·简住的地方。
So just all of a sudden, like everything changed overnight in her neighborhood. You have groups of people. I mean, you even sometimes have groups of 25, 30 people walking in a street with no sidewalk and narrow street. So she said like a lot of these tourists were cool, but definitely not all of them. So people would urinate on lawns. She said at some point, someone actually hit her car, and she started filming bad behavior by tourists and her neighborhood.
所以转眼之间，她社区里的一切在一夜之间都变了。你会看到一群群的人。我的意思是，有时你甚至会看到25、30人成群结队地走在一条没有行人路且很窄的街道上。所以她说，这些游客中虽然有很多挺酷的，但绝对不是全部。比如有人会在草坪上小便。她说有一次，真的有人撞了她的车，于是她开始拍摄游客在她社区里的不良行为。
I have a film about her neighborhood. It's only a half hour long. It has been a struggle to keep it at a half hour. But I have hours and hours and hours of footage. People breaking the law and gridlock streets. And whenever I put anything new in, I try to take something out. Have you seen this video? I was not actually allowed to see the video so she doesn't post it online because she's worried about people finding out where she lives. But I've been told it's really dramatic.
我有一部关于她社区的电影。它只有半小时长。要把它控制在半小时以内真是一场挣扎。但我有数不清的素材。人们违法乱纪，街道交通瘫痪。每当我把新的内容放进去时，我都会尽量删掉一些旧的。你见过这段视频吗？其实我没被允许看这段视频，因为她没有把它发到网上，她担心人们会顺藤摸瓜找到她住的地方。但据我所知，它非常具有戏剧性。
They actually have all this footage set to Stravinsky's ballet, the right of spring. So like the most dramatic music you can imagine. So it's not just peeing in yards and stuff. Like there's all that bad behavior, but Sarah Jane says her biggest worry has always been fires. You know, she's in Southern California, she's near a lot of dry brush.
他们实际上把所有的这些素材都配上了斯特拉文斯基的芭蕾舞曲《春之祭》。也就是你能想象到的最具戏剧性的音乐。所以这不仅仅是在院子里小便之类的事。所有这些糟糕的行为都有，但莎拉·简说，她最大的担忧一直是火灾。你知道的，她住在南加州，附近有很多干燥的灌木丛。
And while California was having these horrible fires, I look across the street and I see somebody smoking, you know, in front of my house. Huh, so what is she done about this? So Sarah Jane, like her full time occupation now, is being an advocate for less tourist access to the Hollywood side. She wants the city to stop promoting it
正当加州发生这些可怕的火灾时，我看着街对面，发现有人居然在我家门前抽烟。哈，那她对此做了什么？所以莎拉·简现在可以说是把全职工作都用来倡导减少游客对好莱坞标志的访问了。她希望市政府停止将其宣传为
as a tourist destination. Many of her neighbors were also part of this campaign and some of them started going a little too far. What, like what do you mean? You remember we did this episode about informal interventions, so like informal urbanism, like people kind of taking things into their own hands. So some of Sarah James neighbors were doing things like painting curbs red to indicate there's no parking,
旅游目的地。她的许多邻居也参与了这场运动，其中一些人甚至开始做得有点过分了。什么，你这话是什么意思？还记得我们做过的那期关于非正式干预的节目吗？也就是非正式的城市主义，比如人们把事情掌握在自己手中。所以莎拉·简的一些邻居开始做一些事情，比如把路缘石漆成红色以表示禁止停车，
putting up signs that said things like there is no access to the Hollywood sign here. And I saw one that just said no tourist zones, tourist must leave, which is pretty aggressive. And it's not a legal sign clearly. No, absolutely not. And here's the biggest one. So Roman, I need you to pull out your phone right now
竖起写有诸如“此路不通，无法前往好莱坞标志”等字样的标牌。我还看到一个上面只写着“禁止游客区，游客必须离开”，这就相当具有攻击性了。而且这显然不是一块合法的路标。不，绝对不是。还有最重要的一点。所以罗曼，我现在需要你掏出手机，
and pull up the mapping software on your phone. All right. So type in the Hollywood sign and then ask for directions from anywhere else in LA. So like LA City Hall. Okay, Hollywood sign, directions, you go up the 101, you get off on Vermont Avenue, and then it brings you basically to the Griffith Observatory.
打开你手机上的地图软件。好的。输入好莱坞标志，然后请求从洛杉矶的其他地方导航。比如从洛杉矶市政厅出发。好的，好莱坞标志，路线，走101国道，从佛蒙特大道下高速，然后它基本上会把你带到格里芬天文台。
That's right, so you probably know the Griffith Observatory, it's like a famous LA landmark, it's in La La Land and lots of other pop culture, but it's not the Hollywood sign. Like it is a 75 minute walk from the Hollywood sign. So people in the neighborhood and the city counselor actually petitioned Google and lots of other mapping softwares and got the location of the Hollywood sign changed on the maps. Alyssa Walker, who's a writer at Curb, she wrote a whole piece in 2014
没错，所以你大概知道格里芬天文台，它是洛杉矶著名的地标，出现在《爱乐之城》和许多其他流行文化中，但它并不是好莱坞标志。从这里走到好莱坞标志还要75分钟呢。所以社区居民和市议员实际上向谷歌以及许多其他地图软件请愿，把地图上好莱坞标志的位置给改了。阿莉莎·沃克（Alyssa Walker），《Curbed》网站的一位作家，她在2014年写了一篇完整的文章，
where she found that it's true of like all the big mapping softwares that they do not send you to the Hollywood sign. So clearly this campaign was pretty effective. So even though it says Hollywood sign, I see the marker for Hollywood sign, but it's letting you off at a place where you can see the Hollywood sign
发现在所有的大型地图软件上都是如此，它们都不会把你直接带到好莱坞标志。所以显然这场运动相当有效。所以尽管上面写着好莱坞标志，我看到了好莱坞标志的标记，但它把你带到一个你可以从格里芬天文台看到好莱坞标志的地方，而不是你可以真正步行走到那个好莱坞标志的地方。完全正确。完全正确。他们的论点是，它把游客送到了一个能看到好莱坞标志的地方，而这正是人们想要的，对吧？不过事实上，我给你发了另一张照片。
from the Griffith Observatory, not where you could actually walk to this Hollywood sign. Exactly. Exactly. And the argument is it's sending tourists to somewhere that has a view of the Hollywood sign, and that's what people want, right? But actually, I sent you another photo.
如果你看一下，这是一张从格里芬天文台远眺好莱坞标志的照片。它小得可怜。是的，真的很小。你几乎看不清。我不知道这是照片没拍好还是本来就如此，但我发给你的那张看起来真的非常小。所以我们应该试试另一个最喜欢的把戏，那就是输入从好莱坞标志到格里芬天文台的路线，看看地图会怎么走。哦，好的。我们来看看。它只是绕圈子。
If you take a look, this is a photo of the view of the Hollywood sign from the Griffith Observatory. It's teeny tiny. Yeah, it's really small. You can barely see it. I don't know if this is a bad photo or this is typical, but the one I sent you is like really small. So we should do the other favorite trick with this, which is type in the directions
是的，它只是让你绕着圈开了五分钟的车。哇，太神奇了。这太卓越了。我对此感到很矛盾，因为我确实理解，你知道的，要在那里待着可能会很困难。如果那里有很多人，基础设施根本无法支撑住宅区里的大量游客。但我是一个坚定的公共资源信仰者，我们应该允许人们穿过属于公共土地的地方以及所有诸如此类的事情。所以。嗯，完全正确。
from the Hollywood sign to the Griffiths Observatory and see what the map does. Oh, okay. Here we go. And it just loops around. Yeah, it just tells you to drive in a circle for five minutes. Wow, that's amazing. That is remarkable. I feel conflicted about this because I do understand, you know, it can be difficult to
我的意思是，当你从更高的层面来思考时，这是一个关于人们试图保护旅游目的地免受游客侵害的故事，对吧？就像试图把人们引导到错误的地方一样。我的意思是，很多人对莎拉·简和这个社区的人提出了批评，认为他们是邻避主义者。人们总是很快就会说：“哦，这只是邻避主义。”
be there. If there's lots of people there, that the infrastructure wasn't there to support a bunch of tourists and a residential neighborhood. But I'm a big believer in public resources and that we should allow people to walk through places that are public land and all kinds of other things like that. So. Well, exactly.
当事实并非如此时，这里存在着巨大、巨大的安全隐患。就像我多少有点同情他们，因为我确实能体谅到，当我的社区举办特殊活动，汽车淹没整个社区并让生活变得很不方便时那种感受。但这也像是身处城市的一部分。总有些地方是人们想要去的。如果你身处一个令人向往的地方，你知道的，人们就会涌现。所以我对此感到非常纠结。
And I mean, when you think about it on a bigger level, it's a story about people trying to protect a tourist destination from tourists, right? Like trying to send people to the wrong place. I mean, there's like a lot of criticism of Sarah Jane and the people in this neighborhood that they're being nimbis. People are really quick to say, oh, this is just nimbism.
但我认为我更倾向于支持罗曼。我觉得我们是一个总体上持支持态度的节目。那现在情况怎么样了？所以莎拉·简，她这一方其实赢得了一场胜利。她家附近的那个步道口已经被关闭了，它在2017年被关闭。所以她说这确实限制了来访的人数。现在她每天只能看到大约30到50名游客。但也有人在努力寻找某种更大规模的解决方案，
When it's not, there are huge, huge safety issues here. Like I am somewhat sympathetic because I do recognize when there's a special event in my neighborhood and cars like overrun the neighborhood and make it more difficult to be in. But this seems like this is part of being in a city. There are places that people want to go. And if you are in a place that's desirable, you know, people show up. So I'm really torn about this.
因为这件事情到现在已经持续了将近10年。所以提出的一些解决方案包括也许把好莱坞标志搬到环球影城。其中一个正在被提议的极具创意的解决方案是修建一条能够直接把游客带到标志那儿的缆车。我支持缆车。这绝对是完美的解决方案。无可争议。
But I think I'm kind of pro roaming. I think we're a show that is our stance has been pro roaming in general. So what happens now? So Sarah Jane, her side actually won a victory. The trailhead near her house has been closed down, it closed down in 2017. So she says that's actually limited the number of people who come by. She only sees about like 30 or 50 tourists every day now. But there are people trying to come up with some kind of a bigger solution
对，我的意思是，这是一个好方案。我想其中一个问题是，有人说建造这条缆车可能会花费1亿美元。所以华纳兄弟公司表示他们可能会感兴趣，这家电影制片厂。我不知道，目前还处于相当初期的规划阶段。天哪。
because this has been going on for at this point close to 10 years. So some of the solutions being thrown out are maybe moving the Hollywood sign to Universal Studios. One really creative solution that's being proposed is to put up a gondola that actually takes people all the way up to the side. I'm pro gondola. That is the perfect solution. No contest.
说真的，如果你能用一种通俗易懂的办法解决一个问题，那你就是用最好的方式解决了问题。我太喜欢这个主意了。哦，天哪。哦，我太爱了。我太喜欢了。我才不管路上有没有大高塔或者其他什么东西来促成这件事。
Right, I mean, it's a good solution. I think the one issue with it is people say it might cost $100 million to build this gondola. So Warner Brothers said they might be interested, the movie studio. I don't know, it's in like the pretty early planning stages right now. Oh my God.
这必须得发生。好吧，我很高兴我们迎来了一个大团圆结局。即使它只是假设性的。如果不是在现实生活中，那至少在我们的脑海里，你知道的，这是解决整个问题完美方案。我期待着有一天能坐缆车去好莱坞标志。罗曼·马尔斯纪念缆车。那该有多高兴啊。
Seriously, if you can fix a problem with a vernacular, you fix the problem the best way possible. I love that idea. Oh, oh my God. Oh, I love it. I love it. I do not care if there's a big tower in the way or whatever it is to make that happen.
谢谢你讲的故事。谢谢你，罗曼。这是制作人克里斯·巴鲁贝。我现在跟你和伊在一块儿，你要给我们讲一个什么样的故事呢。所以这其实是给“九九PI”这里的一位员工的圣诞礼物，而且我敢肯定，当我讲到那儿时，你一定会猜到它是送给谁的。好的。
That needs to happen. Well, I'm so glad we came to a happy ending. Even if it's hypothetical. If not in real life, then at least in our minds, you know, with the perfect solution to this whole thing. I look forward to taking the gauntlet to the Hollywood side in some day. The Roman Mars Memorial gauntlet. What a joy that would be.
京都有一座著名的佛教寺庙叫平等院（Biodoen），它基本上已经矗立了一千年了，是一个世界遗产，它是如此具有标志性，甚至还印在十日元硬币的背面，但它正遭受攻击。被谁？浣熊。不对。平等院的阁楼实际上闹起了浣熊灾。那我就知道这个故事是送给谁的了。这是送给我们自己的……因为他太喜欢浣熊了。千真万确，当我刚入职的时候。
Thanks for the story. Thank you, Roman. That's producer Chris Barube. So I'm in the studio with you and I, and you're gonna tell us what kind of story. So this is actually a Christmas present for one of the staff members here at Nine-Nine PI, and I'm sure you're gonna guess who it's for when I get there. Okay.
我说我的精神动物是浣熊，他当时整个人惊呆了，给我发了海量的浣熊照片。当时我就想，这——这其实是你的生活方式。这不仅仅是个爱好。他对此非常认真。所以我们前不久做过一期关于多伦多绿色垃圾桶以及它们是如何做到防浣熊的节目。现在我们遇到了一座它们正试图破坏的寺庙。是的，它们就像《侏罗纪公园》里的迅猛龙一样，正在学习如何开门，而且它们的破坏力还在不断升级。不过我刚开头提到了平等院，但实际上日本大约80%的寺庙都遭受过某种形式的浣熊破坏，数量非常庞大。哇。除了翻找垃圾，浣熊还能对寺庙造成什么破坏？它们会抓挠那些自11世纪以来就一直耸立的古老木柱。
So there's this famous Buddhist temple in Kyoto called Biodoean, and it's been standing for basically a thousand years, it's a World Heritage site, and it's so iconic that it's even on the back of the Ten-Yen coin, but it's under attack. By whom? Records. No. The attic of Biodoeen is actually infested with raccoons. Well then I know who this story is for. This is for our own critical stat because he loves raccoons. True story when I first joined on staff. I said that my spirit animal was raccoons and he flipped out and sent me like tons of pictures of raccoons. I was like this is
它们会在天花板上掏洞，撕毁电线和瓦片，而且因为它们是野生动物，它们还会在各处随地大小便。但问题是，浣熊灾难在日本其实是一个相对较新的现象，因为直到20世纪70年代，日本还没有任何野生浣熊。哇。那也没多久以前。它们已经造成了相当大的破坏。所以情况是这样的，你可以把浣熊泛滥的罪魁祸首精确锁定到一个单一的原因，那就是一部动画片。
This is actually a lifestyle for you. It's not just like a thing. He takes it very seriously So we did a story a little bit ago about the green bins and Toronto and how they are made raccoon proof So now we have a temple that they're trying to destroy. Yes, they're just like the Raptors in Jurassic Park, where they're learning how to open doors, and they're escalating. But I mentioned Biotoene off the top, but about 80% of the temples in Japan have suffered some form of raccoon damage, which is huge. Wow. Aside from giving them their garbage, what kind of damage can a raccoon do to a temple? So they're scratching up these ancient wood pillars that have been standing since the 11th
好吧，我得知道这到底是怎么回事。好的，所以在1963年，一位名叫斯特灵·诺斯（Sterling North）的美国作家出版了一本关于他童年的回忆录，书名叫《拉斯卡尔：一个更美好时代的回忆录》（Rascal, a Memoir of a Better Era）。
century. They punch holes in the ceilings and they tear apart wires and tiles and they just, since they're wild animals, they will crap everywhere too. But the thing is, the raccoon menace is actually a relatively new phenomenon in Japan because up until the 1970s There weren't any wild raccoons in Japan. Wow. That's that's not that long ago. They're already doing significant amount of damage So here's the thing you can actually pinpoint the raccoon explosion to a single cause and that was a cartoon. Oh Well, okay, I gotta know what this is about. Okay, so in 1963, an American writer named Sterling North released a memoir about his childhood called Rascal, a memoir of a better era.
故事发生在威斯康星州的农村，他来自一个有点像开拓者类型的家庭，花了很多很多时间在荒野中。但这本书主要讲述了他和他的最好朋友的故事，那是一只活泼可爱的小浣熊，名叫拉斯卡尔。他们会一起做各种各样的事情，比如造独木舟，参加吃派比赛。而且它，你知道的，非常可爱。迪士尼实际上将诺斯的回忆录改编成了1969年的真人电影《拉斯卡尔》。
And this took place in rural Wisconsin, and he came from kind of like a frontiersman type family, and he spent a lot, like a lot of time in the wilderness. But the book was mostly about him and his best friend, which was a spunky baby raccoon named a rascal. And they would do all sorts of things together like build canoes and like enter pietying contests. And it was, you know, adorable. And Disney actually adapted North's memoir into a 1969 live-action movie called Rascal.
我想给你播放一小段拉斯卡尔惹出的各种恶作剧的片段。好的，太好了。很好。谢谢你，拉里。谢谢你，拉里。拉斯卡尔惹了不少麻烦。确实是的。哇。对于听众朋友们来说，刚才那是录音室里一只浣熊从天花板掉到一个女人头上的声音，是一只活生生的浣熊。
And I want to show you a quick clip of the hijinks that Rascal would get into. Okay, great. Good. Thank you, Larry. Thank you, Larry. Rascal got into a lot of trouble. He did, yeah. Wow. For listeners, that was the sound of a raccoon being dropped from the ceiling onto a woman's head, the live raccoon.
对于一部电影来说，这似乎是一个非常简单且荒谬的前提。这部电影当时在日本不知怎么地火了吗？没有，其实并没有，因为在1977年，日本的“日本动画公司”（Nippon Animation）改编了诺斯的小说，他的回忆录。哦，明白了。所以他们实际上把它改编成了一部超级可爱的动画片，名字叫《小浣熊》（Rascal the Raccoon，日语原名：拉斯卡尔）。这部片子可爱得让我简直想死。
That seems like a very simple and ridiculous premise for a movie. Was this movie somehow big in Japan or something? No, not really actually, because in 1977, Nippon Animation in Japan adapted North's novel, his memoir. Oh, okay. So they actually adapted it into this adorable anime series called Adai Guma Rascal. And it's so cute that I want to die.
我们要放主题曲给你听，然后你得……你得打断我，因为我会让它一直放下去。好的，伙计。哦，你在喝汽水吗？对。你在田野里奔跑。这是一只小浣熊。他是个大块头，是个长大的大男孩。
And we'll play you the titles and you're... You're going to have to cut me off because I will let it play forever. Yeah, buddy. Oh you're drinking soda pub? Yeah. You're running through a field. It's a pharacum. He's a big guy, he's a big old boy.
好了，既然大家其实看不见这个画面，也许我应该在这个时候打断你。我能听那首歌听上一整天。哦，太令人愉快了。我甚至想把这首歌加到我的健身播放列表里。所以在1977年，当这部动画片在日本首播时，它引起了轰动。我其实有一个在那个时期左右在日本长大的朋友，我问她，你知道的，只是想向我解释一下
Okay, since people can't actually see this, maybe I should cut you off at this point. I could listen to that song all day. Oh, that was delightful. I kind of want to add that song to like my workout playlist. So in 1977, when this anime debuts in Japan, it's a sensation. And I actually have a friend that grew up in Japan around this time, and I asked her, you know, just to kind of explain to me
这到底有多受欢迎。比如，我可以把它翻译成美国人的概念，她说：“拉斯卡尔的受欢迎程度比米老鼠稍低一点，但比海绵宝宝受欢迎得多。”那真的很受欢迎。这太疯狂了。真的，是的，真的很受欢迎。而且它太可爱了。
how popular this was. Like, I was like, I can translate it to like American terms, and she said, Rascal was slightly less popular than Mickey Mouse, but much more popular than SpongeBob. That's very popular. It's crazy. It's really, yeah, it's really popularBob. That's very popular. It's really pop. And it's so cute.
所以孩子们非常喜欢这部剧。而且拉斯卡尔如此可爱，以至于让浣熊看起来像是非常有趣的伴侣。因此，日本家庭开始从北美进口小浣熊到日本作为宠物养在家里。他们每年进口多达1500只浣熊。哇。我找不到具体进口了多少只的准确数字，但这持续了好几年，直到日本政府不得不介入并禁止进口。
So kids loved this show. And Rascal's so cute that it makes raccoons look like really fun companions. So Japanese families started importing baby raccoons from North America to Japan to keep his pets in their homes. And they were bringing in as many as 1,500 raccoons a year. Wow. And I couldn't find the exact number of how many were imported, but this took place over like multiple years before the Japanese government had to step in and like ban importation.
所以至少有数千只被引入了这个国家。那么我的理解是，这些宠物浣熊中有些逃跑了，然后生下了小浣熊，接着野生浣熊就接管了那里。是的。好吧。但问题是，如果你读了斯特灵·诺斯自传的结尾，他得出的结论是：浣熊其实并不适合当宠物，因为它们是野生动物，随着年龄增长，它们会变得具有攻击性，
So at least a few thousand were introduced in the country. And so I take it that some of these pet raccoons got out and then made baby raccoons and then wild raccoons took over. Yes. Okay. But also here's the thing. So, if you read the end of sterling North's autobiography, he comes to the conclusion that raccoons are not good pets because they're wild animals and they become aggressive
并且会破坏你的房子。确实如此。所以，在回忆录的结尾，诺斯决定把拉斯卡尔放归荒野，因为这是正确的事情。这对他完全没问题，因为他在威斯康星州。哦，我明白了。但日本的许多人最后也选择把他们的宠物浣熊放生到荒野中，
and as they get older they will destroy your house. For sure. So, at the end of his memoir, North decides to release Raskle back into the wilderness because it's the right thing to do. And that's totally fine for him because he's in Wisconsin. Oh, I see. But a lot of the people in Japan also ended up releasing their pet raccoons in the wilderness,
这很糟糕，因为它们是几乎没有天敌的外来入侵物种。所以现在它们正在破坏农作物，毁坏古老的寺庙。而其中最糟糕的部分在于，它们正在危及其日本本土的浣熊替身——也就是狸猫（Tanuki），因为它们之间存在着食物竞争。噢，所以这就像是取代了日本本土的一种替代浣熊生态位的物种。是的。太令人难过了。我以前从没听说过狸猫。太神奇了。哦，这些——这些都好可爱。它们将成为我的新精神动物。我的意思是，我觉得我在流行文化中听过其他类似的事情。
which is bad because they're an invasive species with basically no predators. So now they're destroying crops and they're ruining ancient temples. And kind of the worst part about this is that they're endangering their Japanese raccoon doppelganger, the Tanuki, because they have, you know, this food competition. So. Oh, so it's like displacing a native species that takes the place of a raccoon in Japan. Yes. So sad. I've never heard of a Tanuki. That's amazing. Oh, those are all those are cute. Those will be my new spirit animal. I mean, I feel like I've heard other stuff like this
比如你知道的，70年代时因为《灵犬莱西》的播出，柯利牧羊犬非常火，然后——然后是在《哈利·波特》之后，人们真的想要猫头鹰，你知道的，这也是一种很难照顾的动物。但这通常不会导致某种动物变成外来入侵物种。这只是个坏主意。没错。是的，结果通常只是收容所里多了更多动物。但问题是，我是宝可梦时代的一名儿童。
in pop culture. So like when you know, collies were really big in the 70s when I was a kid because of Lassie and then and and then after Harry Potter, like people really wanted owls, you know, which is not something that's easy to care for either. But it usually doesn't result in something being an invasive species. It's just a bad idea. Exactly. Yeah, it just sends up with like more animals in shelters. But like the thing is, I was a child of the Pokemon generation.
在流行文化中。比如你知道的，在我小时候的70年代，因为《灵犬莱西》的原因，牧羊犬非常受欢迎，然后呢，在《哈利·波特》之后，人们又非常想要猫头鹰，你知道的，这也是一种很难照顾的动物。但这通常不会导致某种动物成为入侵物种。这只是个糟糕的主意。没错。是的，结果只是让救助站里多了更多动物。但问题是，我是宝可梦时代的孩子。
And if Pikachu's were a real thing and an invasive species, I would definitely be shipping Pikachu's into the country. And they would destroy the grid and I would not care. You would not care. I would not care. Too cute. Too cute. So one weird part of this whole situation is that the places being hit the hardest by,
而且如果皮卡丘是真实的物种并且是入侵物种，我绝对会把皮卡丘运进国内。它们会毁掉电网，而我根本不在乎。你不在乎？我不在乎。太可爱了。太可爱了。所以整个情况诡异的一个地方在于，受到冲击最严重的地区……
you know, these raccoons and this raccoon damage are these Buddhist temples and shrines. And they're really, really hard to restore because, you know, they're ancient buildings and you can't really replicate this kind of architecture. But the most effective way to control, you know, invasive species populations is eradication. Right.
你知道，这些浣熊和浣熊造成的破坏主要集中在这些佛教寺庙和神社。而且它们非常非常难修复，因为你知道，它们是古老的建筑，你无法真正复制这种建筑风格。但控制入侵物种数量最有效的方法，你知道的，就是根除。没错。
And if you know anything about Buddhism, one of the core philosophies of Buddhism is that you could never harm a living creature. So it's just like a weird pickle that, you know, Buddhist monks have to be in, where it's like, do you protect the temple or these raccoons be in? Wow. That is a tough choice, because you don't want to kill raccoons, obviously. So what did they end up doing?
如果你对佛教有所了解，佛教的核心哲学之一就是你绝不能伤害任何有情众生。所以这就成了一个尴尬的困境，佛教僧侣们不得不面对，比如，你是保护寺庙还是保护这些浣熊？哇。这真是一个艰难的选择，因为显然你不想杀死浣熊。那他们最后怎么处理的呢？
So there was this special on PBS from 2012 called Raccoons Gone Wild. That featured the Japanese temple problem and it's great. You should probably check it out. It's fun. But I'm going to display you a clip of the conclusion that they come to. These masked aliens have no natural predators here. So the Japanese, including the monks, have adopted a zero tolerance policy. Every year in Japan, over 10,000 raccoons are trapped, then killed.
PBS在2012年播过一期名为《狂野浣熊》的特别节目。节目重点讲述了日本的寺庙问题，非常棒。你或许应该去看看。挺有意思的。但我接下来要给你播放一段他们得出的结论的剪辑。这些戴着面具的外星在这里没有天敌。所以包括僧侣在内的日本人民，采取了零容忍政策。在日本，每年有超过一万只浣熊被捕捉然后杀死。
Whoa, so even the pacifist Buddhist monks, they're going after the raccoons, they're going to kill the raccoons. Yeah, And now that I think about it, a story about murdering his favorite animal, probably was a bad Christmas present for Kurt. Wow. Sorry about that Kurt. Oh, poor little guys. That whole situation is horrible.
哇，所以连爱好和平的佛教僧侣也对浣熊下手了，他们要杀死浣熊。对，现在回想起来，一个关于谋杀他最喜欢的动物的故事，对科特来说可能是一个糟糕的圣诞礼物。哇。真替科特感到遗憾。哦，可怜的小家伙们。整个情况太可怕了。
Yeah, it's not their faults. No, not at all, but you know, you can't have invasive species. You can't introduce them even if they're cute. That's just an important lesson. Well, thanks for that story. I had no idea about that story. Thank you so much. Thank you. We have one more mini story about the things we build to appease the spirit world after this.
是的，这不是它们的错。不，完全不是，但你知道，你不能引进入侵物种。你不能引进它们，即使它们很可爱。这只是一个重要的教训。好吧，谢谢你讲这个故事。我以前完全不知道这个故事。非常感谢。谢谢。接下来我们还有一个关于我们为安抚灵界而建造的事物的微型故事。
about the things we build to appease the spirit world after this. So I'm in the studio with Kurt Colstead, and we've talked about a number of different regional vernacular designs of the years, including the Hillshoist of Australia, the clothesline that is in every suburban backyard in Australia, and is like the pride of Australia. I enjoy. And the German Tilton Turn Windows, which is the pride of Kurt Kohlstead and heated Japanese Kotatsu tables. But you've been accumulating a collection
关于我们为安抚灵界而建造的事物的微型故事。所以我正和科特·科尔施泰德在录音室里，这些年来我们讨论过许多不同的地方本土设计，包括澳大利亚的“希尔斯霍斯特”晾衣架，那个存在于澳大利亚每个郊区后院、堪称澳大利亚骄傲的晾衣架。我很喜欢。还有德国的内开倾转窗，这是科特·科尔施泰德的骄傲，以及带有加热功能的日本炬燵桌。但你一直在收集各种
of even kind of weirder, more esoteric, vernacular designs that are equally interesting, but just a little bit stranger. Yes, yeah, just a little bit different. And we often talk about, you know, regional designs and architecture and how it's shaped by weather or available materials or building codes or things like that. But this subset of designs is culturally specific and it's less associated with, I'm not even sure how to say it exactly, but let's say tangible
更奇怪、更深奥的本土设计，它们同样有趣，只是稍微奇特了一点。是的，没错，就是稍微有那么点不同。我们经常讨论，你知道，地方设计和建筑是如何受到天气、可用材料、建筑规范或诸如此类的因素影响的。但这一类设计具有文化特异性，它与某种东西的联系较弱，我甚至不确定该怎么确切表达，但我们就说它与实质性的……
reason. Right. Right. So we're talking about things like designs that are for warding off ghosts or appeasing spirits or you know, otherwise dealing with figures of myths and legends and one of my favorites is something that's called a witch window, which is a type of fenestration. It's mostly found in the northeastern United States. I think I've seen them in Vermont and I just want to be clear. We talk about which windows we're talking about, which is like green skin,
理由关系不大。对，对。所以我们讨论的是诸如用来驱魔避邪、安抚亡灵、或者说用来应对神话传说中人物的设计，我最喜欢的一种叫做“女巫窗”，这是一种窗户的结构。它主要发现在美国东北部。我想我在佛蒙特州见过它们，我只想澄清一下。我们说女巫窗时，我们指的是那种皮肤呈绿色……
white, you know, like fine on broomstick, which is, and these windows are supposedly designed for them, or toward them off. Right, right. So these are witches flying around on broomsticks. And the idea is that which is, can't pass through these tilted windows to get into buildings. And there's nothing else about this window that says witch.
皮肤苍白，你知道的，骑着扫帚的这种女巫，而这些窗户据说就是为她们设计的，或者是为了把她们挡在外面。对，对。所以这些都是骑着扫帚飞来飞去的女巫。其理念是女巫无法穿过这些倾斜的窗户进入建筑物。而且这个窗户上没有其他任何东西能说明它跟女巫有关。
They're just angled in such a way that they align with the slopes of roofs rather than the straight edges of walls and floors. Right. It's kind of hard to imagine that witches cause these windows. So other explanations as to why they might exist and then maybe the term which window was applied to them after the fact? Yeah, there are definitely other theories about these and there are other names for them too So one of those names is coffin windows and so that might suggest that it was a design choice that would let caskets pass into and Out of upper stories of buildings
它们的角度刚好与屋顶的斜坡保持一致，而不是与墙壁和地板的直线边缘保持一致。真的很难想象女巫会促成这些窗户的出现。那么，对于它们为什么存在的其他解释是什么，或许“女巫窗”这个词是在事后才被安到它们身上的？是的，关于这些窗户确实还有其他理论，它们也有其他名字。其中一个名字叫“棺材窗”，这可能表明这是一种设计选择，可以让棺材进出建筑物的顶层。
You know, there's also very simple explanations like maybe it's just about getting in more natural light It's just a simple hack to fit in full-size windows between different levels of angled rooftops where they wouldn't otherwise fit. Right. So in both of those explanations, what you're trying to get is as big a window as possible and because there's another roof, it's a small story, like a attic or something, you're putting a full-size window at a tilt so that it lines up with the slope of the roof and therefore can be the biggest window possible. So you can get a coffin out of it or you can get more light into it or anything like that. Or you can keep witches out or you can keep witches out.
你知道，还有非常简单的解释，比如这可能只是为了引入更多自然光。这只是一种简单的改造技巧，以便在角度不同的屋顶之间的不同楼层之间塞进全尺寸的窗户，否则它们就塞不进去。没错。所以在这两种解释中，你想得到的是尽可能大的窗户，而且因为有另一个屋顶，这是一个狭小的空间，比如阁楼什么的，你把一个全尺寸的窗户倾斜放置，这样它就能与屋顶的斜坡对齐，从而成为可能的最大窗户。这样你就可以把棺材抬出来，或者让更多光线照进去，诸如此类。或者你可以把女巫挡在外面，或者你可以把女巫挡在外面。
And so these types of architectural flourishes that are meant to ward off spirits, this is not unique to the witches of New England. They're all over the south too. Oh yeah, yeah. In the American South, you can find, for example, blue paint on the ceilings of porches, and that's something that's called paint. And this is said by some to ward off ghosts or spirits. And the idea here is that spirits will maybe confuse the blue for water, and since they don't want to pass over water, they'll stay out. Or another theory that
所以这些旨在辟邪的建筑装饰，并不是新英格兰女巫所特有的。它们在南部也到处都是。哦，是的，是的。在美国南部，你可以发现，例如，门廊的天花板上刷着蓝色的油漆，这被称为“门廊蓝”。据说这可以辟邪或驱鬼。这里的想法是，鬼魂可能会把蓝色误认为水，既然它们不想跨过水，就会待在外面。或者另一个理论是……
kind of runs in parallel is that they'll confuse it for sky. And because they can fly in the sky, they'll fly up towards it instead of flying into your house. I lived in this out for a long time, and I was always told that the blue paint on a roof was to attract mosquitoes away from you sitting on the porch, and they would go up to the blue in the ceiling. Well, yeah, so there's a couple of theories that involve mosquitoes too. And one is that essentially, yeah, they confuse the blue for sky, like the ghost's wood, and they fly up instead of towards you. And another one is that essentially because blue paint used to be made with LI,
与此并行的一种说法是，它们会把蓝色误认为天空。因为它们可以在天空中飞翔，所以它们会朝着蓝色飞去，而不是飞进你的家里。我在南方住了很长一段时间，别人总是告诉我，屋顶上的蓝色油漆是为了吸引蚊子，不让你坐在门廊上时被叮咬，蚊子会飞向天花板上的蓝色。好吧，是的，所以还有几个理论也涉及蚊子。其中一个是，基本上，是的，它们像鬼魂一样把蓝色误认为是天空，它们向上飞而不是向你飞来。另一个理论是，基本上因为蓝色油漆过去是用石灰制作的……
which is of this caustic material, that it actually worked as an insect repellent altogether. So it would just keep mosquitoes away from you. And then there's like aesthetic reasons to Victorian traditions of painting houses in natural colors. I mean, there's all kinds of reasons that this could have started as a tradition. Right. So it's fair to say that some of these stories might be sort of retroactive explanations rather than the cause of it.
石灰是一种腐蚀性材料，它实际上可以完全起到驱虫剂的作用。所以它能让蚊子远离你。然后还有一些美学原因，比如维多利亚时代用自然色彩粉刷房屋的传统。我的意思是，这项传统开始的原因有各种各样。没错。所以公平地说，其中一些故事可能是一种事后诸葛亮的解释，而不是造成这种现象的真正原因。
Like it isn't early spirits or witches. It might be these other things, but you apply this good story of folklore to them, and it's a way applying folklore to what is a much more practical decision, really. Yeah, that's absolutely fair to say. And in some cases, it's really not clear, but there are cases where beliefs really do shape design.
就像它不是早期的幽灵或女巫一样。可能是这些其他的事情，但你把这个美好的民间传说故事套用在它们身上，这是一种将民间传说应用到实际上更具实用性的决策上去的方式。是的，这样说绝对很公平。在某些情况下，确实很不明确，但在某些情况下，信仰确实塑造了设计。
A good example of this is found in Thailand, another Southeast Asian countries, where there are actually purpose-built structures called spirit houses. The idea here is that instead of trying to keep spirits out of your house, you invite them to stay in a different house altogether, something custom-built for their needs. Wow. So just houses devoted to spirits so they don't occupy your own? them to stay in a different house altogether, you know, something custom built for their needs. So just houses devoted to spirit so they don't occupy your own. Yeah, yeah, and they look good too. I mean, I live there. Of course. Why not? In also in Southeast Asia, we've talked about this before, the dragon gates in skyscrapers. Oh yeah, yeah. I mean, and those are really big and really obvious and Pretty new too. I think it basically they look like a giant
这方面的一个很好的例子可以在泰国和其他东南亚国家找到，那里实际上有专门建造的被称为“神龛”的结构。这里的理念是，你不是试图把鬼魂挡在房子外面，而是邀请它们住在另一栋完全不同的房子里，这是专门为它们的需求定制的。哇。所以只是专门供奉鬼魂的房子，这样它们就不会占据你自己的房子？邀请它们住在另一栋完全不同的房子里，你知道的，这是专门为它们的需求定制的。所以只是专门供奉鬼魂的房子，这样它们就不会占据你自己的房子。对，对，而且它们看起来也很不错。我的意思是，我在那里住过。当然。为什么不呢？同样在东南亚，我们以前讨论过这个问题，摩天大楼里的“龙门”。哦，是的，是的。我的意思是，那些非常大、非常明显而且相当新。我想基本上它们看起来像是一个巨大的
wound up in punched a hole all the way through a skyscraper And the theory behind them is that these holes these gaps in the skyscrapers allow dragons to fly back and forth between the water below and the mountains above Wow, and when you think about that in, like skyscrapers are pretty new phenomenon. So this is really taking the superstitions into account is a modern tradition. Yeah, very modern. And as a consequence, a lot of big name modern architects have had to contend with these belief systems
在摩天大楼中间打了个洞。其背后的理论是，这些洞、摩天大楼中的这些间隙允许巨龙在下面的水域和上面的山脉之间飞来飞去。哇，当你考虑到这一点时，摩天大楼是一个相当新的现象。所以把迷信考虑在内其实是一个现代传统。是的，非常现代。因此，许多大牌现代建筑师不得不应对这些信仰体系……
when they're working in Hong Kong. And sort of famously, the Bank of China Tower by IMP got a lot of grief for ignoring Feng Shui experts and geomansers. And so when fostering partners came along and started designing the HSBC Bank Building nearby, they took Feng Shui advice really seriously. And so on their structure, among other things,
当他们在香港工作时。颇具名气的是，贝聿铭设计的香港中银大厦因为忽视了风水专家和风水师而受到了很多非议。因此，当福斯特建筑事务所来设计附近汇丰银行大楼时，他们非常认真地对待风水建议。因此在他们的建筑上，除其他事项外……
there are these maintenance cranes on top. And if you look at them, they look kind of like cannons pointed at the I&P building. And they serve a practical purpose, but symbolically they're meant to deflect the other buildings negative energies. So they're just permanently there poised to attack the other building? Yeah. And they take away evil spirits. Yeah.
顶部有这些维护吊车。如果你仔细看，它们看起来有点像对准贝聿铭大厦的大炮。它们有实际的用途，但在象征意义上，它们旨在抵消其他建筑物的负能量。所以它们就永久地立在那里，随时准备攻击另一栋建筑？是的。并且它们能赶走邪灵。是的。
And they really look like it too. I mean, you look at them and you think, you don't think crane, you think, that's like a cannon up there. Well, it's a pretty ostentatious display or disapproval of somebody else's disregard for the spirit world. Oh yeah, very much so.
而且它们看起来确实很像。我的意思是，你看一眼就会想，你不会觉得那是吊车，你会觉得，那上面就像一门大炮。嗯，这是一种相当炫耀的展示，或者说对其他人忽视灵界的一种不满。哦，是的，非常明显。
And so some of them are about that, right? They're about being ostentatious and obvious, but there are a lot of these things around us that we don't necessarily even think about when we see them. So for example, there's a tradition called Topping Out, which has its roots in Scandinavia. And historically the idea was that you'd put a tree or a wreath on top of a new house or some other building, and that would appease the tree spirits. So it was like a thank you to the forest for providing the wood that was used to make the architecture.
所以其中一些就是关于这个的，对吧？它们是为了炫耀和引人注目，但我们周围有许多这样的东西，当我们看到它们时甚至不一定会去想。例如，有一个叫做“封顶”的传统，它起源于斯堪的纳维亚。历史上这个想法是，你会在新房子或其他建筑的顶部放一棵树或一个花环，用来安抚树木之灵。所以这就好比是对森林提供建造建筑所用木材的一种感谢。
Oh, I've seen these unskyscrapers, but without all the accompanying lords, they'll put a ceremonial tree at the top of a building. And I didn't know there was a real explanation for that. Yeah, and often there's not. Often you just kind of see it and you're like, oh, that's a neat thing that you do at the end, like cutting a ribbon. Right. And that's partly what's fascinating to me about these things is that there's this back and forth between the function of the folklore, and sometimes you see one more obviously than the other.
哦，我在摩天大楼上见过这些，但没有所有这些随之而来的传说，他们会在建筑物顶部放一棵仪式性的树。我以前不知道这背后有什么真正的解释。是的，通常是没有的。通常你只是看到它，然后你会想，哦，这是你在最后做的一件巧妙的事情，就像剪彩一样。没错。这也是让我对这些东西着迷的部分原因，那就是民俗的功能之间存在着这种来回的互动，有时你会比其他时候更明显地看到其中一个。
And it can be hard at times to separate the two. So gargoyles are a classic example, right? They have these supernatural associations, but they're also part of a very pragmatic drainage system for buildings. And welcome mats too. We see those everywhere, and we think those are very practical for wiping off your dirty boots. But this idea of having something with symbols on it or words on it that wards off or welcomes people at thresholds
有时很难将两者分离开来。所以怪兽排水口就是一个经典的例子，对吧？它们具有这些超自然的联系，但它们也是建筑物非常务实的排水系统的一部分。还有门垫也是。我们到处都能看到它们，我们认为这些对于擦掉你脏靴子上的泥土非常实用。但这种在门槛上有符号或文字的东西的想法，能够辟邪或欢迎人们……
goes back thousands of years. So it can be a real challenge in some cases to tell what came first. The practical or the spiritual reasoning behind a particular design strategy. Yeah. And so you've collected a bunch of these on the web, right? So people can read more about them. Oh yeah, I've written about some of these and put some images on there to you. So you can check them all out. Cool. You can check that out at nnipei.org. Thanks Kurt. Yeah, any time. anytime. We will hear more mini stories from the rest of the 99% visible crew as the first episode of 2020. We're gonna take a little bit of time off. We hope you do too. Happy New Year. Be Do too, Happy New Year. As of the end of 2019, 99% invisible is Avery Truffman, Katie Mingle, Kurt Colstad, Delaney Hall, Sharif Yusif, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sean Riel, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Le, Sophia Klatsker,
可以追溯到几千年前。因此，在某些情况下，要分辨究竟是什么先生效，确实是一个真正的挑战。某个特定设计策略背后是实用性还是精神层面的理由。是的。所以你在网上收集了许多这类东西，对吧？所以人们可以阅读更多关于它们的信息。哦，是的，我写过其中一些，并在上面放了一些图片。所以你可以把它们全都看一遍。酷。你可以在nnipei.org上查看。谢谢科特。不客气，随时奉陪。我们将在2020年第一集里听到来自99%无形团队其余成员的更多微型故事。我们要休息一小段时间。希望你们也是。新年快乐。也祝你们新年快乐。截至2019年底，“99%无形”团队成员包括艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、凯蒂·明格、科特·科尔施泰德、德莱尼·霍尔、谢里夫·尤西夫、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、肖恩·里尔、乔·罗森伯格、维维安·勒、索菲亚·克拉茨克、
Chris Baroube, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 9.1.7 KALW in San Francisco, we produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown, Bokeland, California. 99% invisible is a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows and all of podcasting. Support them all at radiotopia.fm. This is the part of the show where I tell you to go to the different social channels
克里斯·巴鲁比，还有我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山9.1.7 KALW的项目，我们在美丽的加州奥克兰市中心的“广播街”制作节目。99%无形是来自PRX的Radio Topia的自豪成员，这是一个极具独立精神的播客界最具创新性节目的集合体。请在 radiotopia.fm 上支持他们所有人。节目到了这一部分，我要请大家去不同的社交渠道
to interact with us, but the best way you can interact with us right here at the end of the year is go to radiotopia.fm and donate to support this show and all the shows in radiotopopia. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与我们互动，但在年终岁尾，你能与我们互动的最好方式就是前往 radiotopia.fm 并进行捐赠，以支持这个节目以及 radiotopia 上的所有节目。来自 PRX 的 Radio topia。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。